that's good hahaha oh well oh well very
funny guys and blast off let's start by
asking a simple question why are we here
shouldn't you know the answer to that of
course baron because that was a
rhetorical question okay we just need to
brainstorm five ideas but to be safe
let's come up with 50 let's make it a
hundred
any idea is welcome when brainstorming
literally anything you say will be
discussed in detail without criticism my
brain just stormed an idea how about we
call off this meeting until Kristen gets
back come on that's a bad idea
I thought we weren't gonna criticize
ideas fine yeah let's put it on the
board any other ideas we're going to a
brainstorm hole I can literally say
anything right now racism racism great a
nice Jesus crisis a nightmare
what's that matter oh I just said that
this is a nightmare this is a nightmare
great you know this reminds me of when I
was selling cigarettes wholesale to
health food stores back in the 70s at
the time we didn't know they were bad
for you or actually we did know but we
kept a lid on it
back then you were allowed to have
secrets secrets from the government from
your wife
it didn't matter I oh my grandma died
doing what she loved most sitting in her
chair worrying that I'm gay hey fellas
lucky when you're dead nobody expects
anything from you death is the
retirement package you get for a
lifetime quote pain suffering that's why
I say you should always bring a gun to a
knife fight or a knife to a gunfight if
you wish
now you might die but at least no one
can say you weren't interesting thank
you so much bill very helpful does it
have a coherent idea hey guys guys can
we get off our phones and focus up you
know we didn't used to have phones in
meetings back then if you wanted to send
someone a nudie pic you had to show up
at their door wearing just a trench coat
and show them what you've got your
thoughts yeah well bill makes a good
point here Oh
here's an idea how about we try
something new and have everyone in the
room put their phones in this box
[Music]